WERE UNDERSTOOD.
BRET.
>> Bret: DOUG McKELWAY,
THANK YOU.
AS IF THE CORONAVIRUS IS NOT
ENOUGH TO WORRY ABOUT, HURRICANE
SEASON IS APPROACHING AND THAT
WILL PUT AN INCREDIBLE STRAIN ON
ALREADY STRESSED FEDERAL
EMERGENCY MANAGERS.
CORRESPONDENT GILLIAN TURNER
SHOWS US HOW TONIGHT.
>> AS CORONAVIRUS CONTINUES
CLAIMING AN AVERAGE OF 2,000
AMERICAN LIVES PER DAY, CRISIS
RESPONSE TEAMS ARE NOW BRACING
FOR ANOTHER ADDED THREAT.
>> ALREADY RESPONDING TO
TORNADOES AND EARTHQUAKES THAT
HAVE OCCURRED.
JUNE 1ST IS HURRICANE SEASON.
THEY HAVE TO BE PREPARED.
AT THE SAME TIME THAT THEY ARE
RESPONDING TO COVID.
>> THE THREAT LANDSCAPE THAT THE
HOMELAND SECURITY CHIEF SAYS IS
UNPRECEDENTED.
>> FEMA IS COORDINATING RESPONSE
IN 50 STATES, TERRITORIES, ALL
HITTING AT THE SAME TIME.
THEY HAVEN’T DONE THAT IN THEIR
41 YEAR HISTORY.
>> FEMA’S ADMINISTRATOR SAYS
THAT ALSO CREATES A LOGISTICS
PUZZLE.
>> ACCELERATING THE MOVEMENT OF
PPE.
WHERE WE CAN FIND IT.
>> OVER THE PAST MONTH, DHS
BUILT A NEW CRISIS RESPONSE
CENTER.
150 OFFICIALS WILL OVERSEE
HURRICANE SEARCH, RESCUE AND
EVACUATION OPERATION ALL WHILE
KEEPING AMERICANS SAFE FROM
CONTRACTING CORONAVIRUS.
>> HOW DO YOU SHELTER
INDIVIDUALS FROM A NATURAL
DISASTER IN A COVID ENVIRONMENT?
YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE TO DO
THINGS A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY.
>> THE SURGE IS MEANT TO SUPPORT
THE CRISIS RESPONSE CELLS
ALREADY OPERATING A FEMA
HEADQUARTERS.
HE WILL FILL UP AS NEEDED, SO
THEY HOPE IT NEVER HAS TO.
>> YEAR PLANNING FOR ALL KINDS
OF SCENARIOS.
WHAT IS THE WORST-CASE SCENARIO?
>> WORST-CASE SCENARIO WOULD BE
A VERY HECTIC HURRICANE SEASON,
THAT WOULD SEE MULTIPLE
HURRICANES HITTING AT THE SAME
TIME OR SIMILAR" BY THAT FEMA IS
HAVING TO RESPOND TO.
THAT’S NOT TO SAY THEY CAN’T DO
IT.
THEY CAN DO IT.
>> 16 AMERICANS DIED IN
HURRICANES LAST SEASON AND SO
FAR OVER 76,000 AMERICANS HAVE